It's officially Canada Day,
so it's the perfect time
to appreciate Canada's
hunky prime minister,
the man who makes people say
"Oh, Canada"--
Justin Trudeau.
(audience shrieking, whooping)
Yeah, you want to give him
some head of state.
Uh, he's become
so popular, in fact,
that he's just about to join
the Marvel Universe.
Trudeau is set to appear,
uh, on a variant cover
of an upcoming issue of
Civil War II: Choosing Sides.
I'm guessing he's the only man
with the power
to convince Dr. Doom
to give away free health care.
So, comedians, I want you
to come up with some more powers
a Canadian super hero
might have in 60 seconds.
Go ahead, Adam.
Uh, radioactive
passive-aggression.
Points. Adam again.
Being... being very,
very, very, very sorry.
All right, points.
Jim.
The ability, uh,
to call pastrami smoked meat.
Points. Adam.
Uh, the power
to knock you the (bleep) oot.
Points. Morgan.
The power to be
equally hot and boring.
Points. Morgan again.
The power to destroy
your enemies when you find one.
Points. Jim.
The ability
to complain about America
but emulate America completely.